vous êtes sur rtl
[Musique]
le grand jury rtl le figaro lci
invitée aujourd'hui françois bayrou haut
commissaire au plan président du
mouvement démocrate le débat est dirigée
par olivier bost
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce grand
jury dans ce grand studio de rtl bonjour
françois bayrou joue merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui françois bayrou qui les
lancent ce début de second quinquennat
emmanuel macron a été réélu il ya trois
semaines et depuis depuis papa de
nouveau premier ministre pas de nouveau
gouvernement
pas de précision non plus sur un
programme de réforme qui n'a pas été
très partagée pendant la campagne
présidentielle
alors nous parlerons ensemble de sur ce
programme de réformes et puis de
transition écologique de pouvoir d'achat
d'éducation notamment nous parlerons
aussi de cette nouvelle méthode qui a
promis emmanuel macron là encore sans en
dire beaucoup plus à mes côtés pour vous
interroger adria geindre de tf1/lci
bonjour noël lee de tf1 lci pour relayer
vos questions sur tous les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag le grand jury et
pour vous poser la première question
guillaume roquette pour le figaro oui
olivier bost disais à l'instant ça fait
trois semaines que manuel macron a été
réélu pression de la république et on
n'a toujours pas de nouveau gouvernement
pourquoi est ce que ça prend autant de
temps françois bayrou
alors vous savez il ya des démocraties
beaucoup dans le monde et j'ai toujours
pensé qu'elle était bien inspiré qui
entre l'élection et l'entrée en fonction
ont une période
deux mois en général
pour pour s'installer pour réfléchir
pour se peser pour constituer des
équipes c'est le cas je disais aux états
unis de moi j'ai un souvenir très précis
j'étais
à l'époque amis de rosser maria aznar
quand il a été élu à la tête de
l'espagne
et
il a eu le temps je suis allé le voir
chez lui
avec sa femme on april après midi pour
discuter il s'agit d'une réélection la
wii si pour moi c'est la même chose il
n'est pas inutile et je trouve que on
devrait le réfléchir
institutionnellement d'avoir quand
l'élection est finie une période où l'on
se pose pour mettre les choses en ordre
et pour peut-être constituer de
nouvelles équipes ça veut dire car
honnêtement non à l'heure où nous
parlons le ou la prochaine première
ministre ou prochain premier ministre
est déjà en train de constituer son
équipe
gibbs requête vous avez c'est bien vous
avez de l'humour donc on va non je ne je
ne crois pas je crois pas que ce soit à
ce stade ça va l'être
mais je pense même qu on aurait eu
plusieurs si je pense même mais c'est un
jugement personnel que j'ai souvent
exprimé je pense qu'on aurait pu
imaginer que le gouvernement de jean
castex aille jusqu'aux élections
législatives mais il n'a pas voulu le
président de l'ape a souhaité mais vous
voyez cette cet intermède à cette
période d'internât elle va être
évidemment marquée par le résultat des
élections législatives et il n'est donc
pas stupides qu'on prenne un peu de
temps à réfléchir à tout ça et vous
disiez franc soleil et vous prenez des
exemples on parle de deux mois là ça
fait trois semaines est ce qu'on doit se
préparer à ce que c'est la dure encore
plusieurs notre planète ne me fait pas
dire adrien joindre ce que je n'ai pas
dit en aucune manière je n'ai je pense
que le président de la république a
clairement indiqué ce qu'était le
déroulement et le déroulement fait que
c'est dans la semaine qui vient qu'on va
avoir la réponse aux questions que si
impatiemment vous vous posez et qu'il
est légitime de se poser parce que la
situation
nationale internationale et mondiale sur
moi une situation d'une gravité
est ce que vous connaissez si lourde si
lourde que ça mérite de
comprennent qu'on prenne les choses à
bras le corps est ce que vous connaissez
le nom du prochain premier ministre non
noel lee avec une question sur les
réseaux sociaux une question de jean luc
sur facebook qui vous demande monsieur
bayrou rêvez vous de devenir premier
ministre
il ya longtemps que je sais que la
politique ce n'est pas le rêve la
politique c'est passer simplement la
mise en ordre j'allais dire la mise en
musique de ses idéaux dans le réel et
donc c'est une fonction très éminente
dans la république j'ai j'ai autrefois
essayer de conquérir la fonction
supérieure et je les fais avec beaucoup
de bonheur est bon vous a été candidat à
la présidence de la cour et plusieurs
fois même trois fois et donc et c'était
une très grande et très belle aventure
dans beaucoup de nos compatriotes se
souviennent chaleureusement et moi aussi
donc
on a le devoir d' occuper les postes de
responsabilité quand on croit à quelque
chose et je ne me suis jamais écarté de
ce devoir là simplement vous voyez bien
que le portrait robot aujourd'hui ne
correspond pas exactement
en tout cas du point de vue génétique à
ce que at il annoncé est ce qu'il est
important pour vous justement que ce
soit une femme premier ministre
c'est moins important que les autres
caractéristiques de cette fonction
aujourd'hui éminente dans une situation
si lourde qu'on peut pas s'en abstraire
mais c'est évidemment significative par
rapport à la tante de la société autant
que nous vivons je vous rappelle qu'il
n'y a eu qu'une femme edith cresson qui
a été nommé premier ministre françois
mitterrand et hier matin justement elle
dénonce encore dans le journal du
dimanche où elle s'exprime une classe
politique qui reste à ses yeux encore
aujourd'hui machiste est ce que c'est
une analyse que vous partagiez ce
qu'aujourd'hui les français
j'ai beaucoup de mal à juger les gens à
partir de leur genre
je le dis d'autant plus que comme tout
le monde le sait ici j'ai travaillé
toute ma vie avec des femmes en leur
faisant une confiance
très fondée
mais pour moi ça n'était pas d'abord des
femmes ou c'étaient des femmes et
des partenaires de confiance absolue
des bras droit je pense marielle de
sarnez évidemment des bras droit d'aider
des personnalités mais ce doit être
après les personnalités l'as politique
alors est-ce que je suis représentatif
dans
le savez il ya beaucoup d'hommes
misogyne il se trouve que je suis adam
fils jean mais je ne savent dire
beaucoup de gens qui ont beaucoup
d'hommes qui des tests de féminité moi
j'aime la framboise et la question
autrement est ce que ça veut dire qu
emmanuel macron est trop exclusivement
encore aujourd'hui entourée d'hommes et
exclusivement d'hommes écoutez vous êtes
en train de de me dire qu'il va nommer
une femme premier ministre et moi-même
va le faire et vous fait le procès du
fait que qu' il est entouré
je ne suis pas pour les univers unis
genre est
unisexe je suis pour les univers mixte
et je trouve que c'est dans la mixité
c'est dans le regard que les emporte sur
les autres que se trouve la richesse de
l'humanité rien il ya un texte
formidable de rilke que j'ai lu très
récemment
qui dit ça et c'est magnifique
d'imaginer que ces deux partis de
l'humanité un jour réussiront à faire
des choses que seule elle n'aurait pas
pu faire ni les unes ni les autres donc
vous considérez que aujourd'hui à une
sorte d'obligation morale a nommé à
matignon je n'ai 1 je ne me suis pas
prononcé sur ce sujet c'est vous qui me
dit ça c'est les journaux qui disent
tous et puis c'est probablement auprès
du président de la république que cette
assemblée
probablement donc je considère que en
effet ça a une signification pour la
société française et puis pour le monde
politique dont la nature
le caractère
souvent violents souvent excessif
souvent sans nuance
et pour ma part pour est à mes yeux
pardon une faiblesse alors est ce que ça
veut dire que toutes les femmes sont non
excessive non violente je ne dirais pas
non plus tout parce que je j'ai beaucoup
de mal à enfermer les êtres humains dans
leur dans leur génétique de naissance de
tout à l'heure vous part je pense que
les êtres humains c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça les êtres humains c'est
100% leur génétique 100% y met et 100%
leur vie et peut-être 100% quelque chose
d'autre totalement et donc de 7
ce mélange absolument subtil qui fait
que nous sommes des êtres différents
avec des qualités différentes des
aspirations différentes et j'espère un
potentiel différents c'est tout ça qui à
mes yeux c'est la richesse de l'humanité
je déteste tellement le ferme honneur
tout à l'heure pour le poste de premier
ministre vous parlez de plusieurs
caractéristiques
au delà du genre quelles sont les
caractéristiques par rapport à la
période à l'époque pour ce second
quinquennat qui sont important à vos
yeux pour cette nomination c'est une
responsabilité très importante et très
difficile et spécialement très
importante et très difficile aujourd'hui
que faut-il un il faut ce qu'on appelle
en anglais mais je connais pas de mots
français meilleur il faut du leadership
il faut la faculté de s'adresser au pays
de dire à ses concitoyens à ses
compatriotes des choses essentielles sur
eux et sur l'avenir qu'on va construire
ensemble et d'être entendue 2 2 il faut
de l'expérience
parce que c'est très difficile imaginez
ce que va être là où s'achalander nature
et dernis très politique nous anime à le
décrire oui c'est plutôt le c'est plutôt
le
pour moi le la caractéristique
principale imaginer l'assemblée
nationale que ce premier ministre
montant à la tribune où cette première
ministre montant la tribune va avoir en
face d'elles s'appelle de l'expérience
gouvernement a le bon goût il faut que
cette personne ait déjà été ministre ce
serait mieux je vais je vais user d'une
parabole dont juste très souvent avec
mes amis si vous avez besoin de
traverser l'atlantique
et s'il ya du mauvais temps
ici le bateau
n'est pas très assurée est ce que vous
préférez choisir comme capitaine
quelqu'un qui a déjà traversé mille fois
l'atlantique où quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
mis les pieds sur un bateau marc edouard
philippe et jean castex n'avais pas
beaucoup d'expérience voudra
gouvernementales non mais ils avaient
l'un et l'autre une expérience de l'état
et ils étaient élus locaux tous les deux
à la tête deux collectivités
importante pour l'un significative pour
l'autre et est-ce qu'il faut françois
bayrou après deux premiers ministres
venus de la droite désormais un premier
ministre venu de la gauche du centre
gauche peut-être
je me tendance à vous dire qu'ils font
auprès du ministre qui soit en phase
avec
le avec la vision du président de la
république et cette vision est une
vision centrale
qui aspirent à dépasser la droite et la
gauche et c'est pas moi qui ait plaidé
pendant 20 années pour que la société
française accepte de rompre avec cette
logique stupide qui consistait à
enfermer les gens dans une guerre de
clans et deux camps d'un côté et
notamment vous dites en termes de signal
parce que par exemple il ya des noms
dans les noms qui circulent ceux
d'elisabeth born in marisol touraine
sont tout à fait dans cet espace central
mais viennent historiquement plutôt du
centre gauche quand catherine vautrin
dans l'ain circulent également bien
plutôt la droite oui je ne je ne juge
pas comme ça je
la troisième caractéristique que vous
indiquez olivier que vous demandiez
olivier bost j'ai dit il faut du
leadership il faut de l'expérience
et il faut
une empathie assez grande avec le
président de la république il faut pas
j'ai connu j'ai connu je vais vous dire
des choses très très simple j'ai connu
un des gouvernements probablement les
plus brillants sur le papier
c'était mitterrand président de la
république michel rocard premier
ministre on peut pas dire que c'était
d'aider un différend qui n'avait pas mis
leadership ni expérience mais ils se
détestaient et quand le président de la
république déteste le premier ministre
les choses ne peuvent que tournait mal
et en tout cas l'ambiance au sommet de
l'état ne doit pas être ça là donc il
faut cette empathie alors je fais un
portrait robot je ne sais pas si cette
fana existe tous ces
exemples existent donc il faut mais pour
moi ce sont les éléments nécessaires
ou qu'ils devraient être nécessaires
pour cette fonction vous avez soufflé
des noms président la république non
encore une question des réseaux sociaux
aurélie oui une question qui vient de
facebook alors aujourd'hui si on vous
proposait un poste au gouvernement est
ce que vous le prendriez et si c'était
possible de quel est ce que vous
choisiriez a priori non a priori pour
quelle raison
parce que
on ne revient pas facilement sur ses
parts j'ai été
ministre de l'éducation nationale
très heureux mini's l'éducation
nationale alors que j'étais très jeune
il y à
presque 30 ans j'y suis resté longtemps
j'ai aimé cette fonction j'ai été
épisodiquement
ministre de la justice au début de ce
quinquennat
empêché pour des raisons complètement
mon choquant mais en face comme ça et je
ne vit jamais de regret de remords et
non a priori non je ne je ne je
n'accepterai pas une fonction liée aux
pro derrière et justement revenons à ce
point vous étiez garde des sceaux vous
avez démissionné après une mise en
examen pour des emplois présumés fictifs
au parlement européen pour votre groupe
l'information judiciaire pardon est
ouvert depuis 2017 et ça en est où
pourquoi ça ça dure si longtemps ça fait
cinq ans parce que on n'a rien trouvé et
rien pu trouver alors probablement ça se
clôturera et moi je mets ce que je dis
là j'ai pas le temps mettant d'iliad
d'acharnement il y a maintenant des
décisions de justice qui montre que ce
que nous disons depuis le début était
vrai c'est à dire que
cette cette affaire est complètement
infondée
alors naturellement ça peut durer
pendant des années
je m'arrête une seconde qui est visé
dans cette affaire le front national
marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon
fabien roussel dans une affaire
similaire vous observerez qu'on n'est
jamais allé voir du côté des grands soi
disant grands autrefois grands partis
jamais pour des raisons politiques
j'en sais rien pour des raisons de
facilité de mai
j'ajoute une chose je n'ai jamais
considéré que le fait qu'un député ed
son parti politique par son avec son
assistant soit en quoi que ce soit
immoral
jeu c'est
d'une certaine manière c'est le
contraire qui ne serait pas enfin bon je
m'arrête pas sur ce point ça peut être
contraire aux lois et règlements mais ça
n'est pas pas immoral mais nous ne
l'avons pas fait revenir à la formation
du gouvernement aujourd'hui trois
ministres issus du modem dans le
gouvernement est-ce qu'il en faut trois
dans le futur gouvernement est ce que
cette question des caraïbes est
importante à vos yeux ma réponse de
président de ce mouvement et il en faut
autant et plus un plus non je je défende
et vous défendez amédée maire de meaux
où on a on a un vivier le dance arena à
présent de rafah c'était un sourire de
ma part mais je vais répondre sur le
fond une de mes fiertés et d'avoir sauvé
et développer un mouvement politique qui
est d'une très grande intégrité et qui a
su faire naître des générations
nouvelles
quand je dis intégrité intégrité sur le
plan
de la philosophie politique
nous partageons des valeurs que mon but
maintenant mais bien que ce terme ne
soit pas idéal pour moi
d'une très grande solidarité entre nous
c'est un commando et c'est un commando
qui a réussi je crois désormais à
enraciner une image dans la vie
politique française pour continuer le
non jeu non seulement une image mais une
réalité une réalité de deux d'une
démarche politique singulière différente
et je crois aujourd'hui apprécié pour
continuer de nous projeter dans le ce
nouveau quinquennat emmanuel macron a
promis une nouvelle méthode est ce que
vous pensez qu emmanuel macron peut
changer
alors il n'a pas dit qui changerait lui
il a dit qu'il faudrait une nouvelle
avait déjà promis de se révolter mais on
ne sait vrai il n'a pas eu l'heur
je pense que c'est très important pour
lui je pense qu'il y a beaucoup réfléchi
je ne sais pas s'il a trouvé toutes les
réponses mais je suis certain que les
réponses devront être trouvés de quoi
s'agit-il alors je vais essayer de le
dire à ma manière à moi qui ne
l'engagent pas lui
quand je parlais du temps critique dans
lequel nous sommes dans la société
française il ya pour moi
un fait aveuglant
c'est qu'il y à une rupture quasi totale
entre la base de la société française
les gens de la vie de tous les jours les
gens qui travaillent les gens qui sont à
la retraite les gens qui sont au chômage
ceux qui ont des enfants ceux qui n'ont
pas de travail ce qui en
est ce qu'ils voudraient progressé enfin
ceux qui sont
le tissus profonds le tissu qui
constitue la société française entre eux
et le sommet où le prétendu sommet de la
société comme en grèce il ya une rupture
absolue
et désespérante si vous regardez la
structuration des votes extrêmes
en tout cas des votes à l'extrême droite
par exemple qui a été au deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle et la
structure de ce vote commandes comme
disent les sociologues qui est te dis ça
très très bien il ya une une homogénéité
total plus vous avez des salaires bas
- vous avez de patrimoine et plus vous
votez dans ce vote qui est un vote de
protestation ou de sécession
pour moi c'est un crève coeur
je calme et hommes vous savez j'habite
toujours le village où je suis né et à
cette heure ci précise sans que je
puisse y être et je les salue par votre
intermédiaire on inaugure
une stèle
sur laquelle il y a le nom des
précédents maire du village et ya le nom
de mon père et la photo nous mon père
que j'ai retrouvé
c'est donc dire que ce sont les miens ce
sont mes les amis mes voisins mes
proches et imaginer que ceux qui sont
qui ont le moins d'avoir le moins de
pouvoir et le moins d'influx ans ne se
reconnaît ou croit revoir le moins
d'influx ans ne se reconnaissent pas du
tout dans ceux qui ont la responsabilité
de diriger des adhérents de pratiquer
sur internet sur l'actuelle méthode non
mais j'y viens yab rock c'est l'échec
des manuels m'accroupir est frac non
c'est l'échec de de combien trois quatre
cinq décennies qui ont au fil du temps
laissé s'amenuiser leuliet ça c'est
peut-être aggraver marine le pen wes
greene et dit je ne je ne sens pas les
choses comme ça je vois que ça on n'a
pas réussi à renverser ce mouvement mais
recommande donc la nouvelle méthode
qu'est ce que c'est la nouvelle méthode
c'est une méthode dans laquelle l'état
et l'administration et le pouvoir
auront trouvé par une organisation
différente le moyen que personne ne
soupçonne que ses responsabilités soi
des privilèges
c'est pas parce que vous êtes en
responsabilité que vous devez être
ressenti comme à privilégier
les méthodes de décision la rapidité de
l'action le vous savez bien que tout se
perd dans les sables on annonce quelque
chose à la télé et puis vous revenez six
mois après rien n'a changé parce que
c'est en cours monsieur le ministre mais
est-ce que par et je pense que je
raconte de tous ceux qui travaillent
avec moi savent que je passe mon temps à
dire oui je vous ai compris c'est en
cours rien de rien ne bouge aussi vite
que ça devrait notamment parce que vous
les réseaux d'information avait
désormais
engagé un rythme qui devrait être le
rythme de l'action perceptible par les
citoyens donc un la simplicité des
échanges la simplicité des réseaux de
commandement la rapidité de l'action et
la personnalisation des choix parce que
on vit dans un univers politique dans
lequel tous les choix qui sont faits
sont faits par des gens pour l'essentiel
anonyme or on doit mettre de la
personnalisent avantage fédrigo associer
les citoyens par exemple pendant ce
quinquennat il ya eu la convention
citoyenne sur le climat avec des
résultats controversés est ce que c'est
un instrument qui est votre point de vue
est intéressant ou est-ce qu'au
contraire il participe comme vous venez
de le dire du ralentissement du
processus de décision parce qu'il faut
constater pendant des mois ce dont je
pense que ça dépend des questions je
pense que que ces conventions peuvent
être utiles sur des sujets très complexe
a rien sur la fin de vie j'ai été très
frappé par l'irlande
vous avez vu que l'irlande dont vous
savez que la tradition catholique du
pays
avec traité sans drame sans
affrontements violents la question si
délicate de lives et g et ils l'ont fait
par des processus qui sont des processus
d'élaboration et de respect des
différentes sensibilités certaines
choses sur la servir yeux qu'on peut
tout à fait envisager ça mais le pour
moi
tout ne peut pas se résoudre nous avons
un parlement
qu'il fasse son travail qu'il assume ses
responsabilités il ya des députés il ya
des sénateurs que qu'il fasse ce qu'il
faut qu'on les aide à faire ce qu'il
faut pour moi le bon équilibre des
institutions c'est un président fort un
gouvernement fort un parlement fort et
pour l'instant on n'est pas encore ils
s'étaient connus à la proportionnelle
parce qu'on n'est pas non plus ça fait
des années vous le
vous voyez bien vous voyez bien les
choses
s'il y a ceux ci lit à ce sentiment de
rupture et de dépossession c'est parce
que personne n'a la certitude que sa
voix soit utile et si vous êtes dans la
majorité vous gagnez tout le pouvoir si
vous êtes dans l'opposition principale
vous en avez vous avez un peu la voix au
chapitre et si vous êtes dans ces
mouvements là qui sont des mouvements
minoritaires alors vous êtes totalement
écarté et ceci est non seulement injuste
mais absurde absurde il n'y a aucune
raison
regardez le les mouvements j'en ai été
pendant longtemps donc je sais
exactement ce qui se passe des
mouvements
substantielle dans la société française
qui portait disent quelque chose ils
n'ont même pas le droit de monter à la
tribune parce qu'ils n'ont pas de député
mais de hong hong hanh à 577 députés
vous trouvez pas que un courant qui
représente quelques millions d'électeurs
devrait avoir sa part normal et légitime
effet pourquoi oui je défends la
proportionnelle qui entraînera un mode
de gouvernement complètement différent
surtout si on arrive à faire que le
parlement ne soit pas perpétuellement
bloqué obstrué
dévié de sa responsabilité comme il
l'est trop souvent monsieur bayrou
justement une galerie de nos internautes
est ce que le rôle d'un président de la
république c'est de gérer les
investitures des candidats aux élections
législatives
tous l'ont fait tout ce qu'on fait à la
suite les uns des autres
de gaulle vérifiait nom par nom
et j'ai connu quelques autres président
de la république que le sujet ne
laissait pas indifférent tous
considèrent que quand on doit constituer
une armée pour porter les sujets bas
c'est normal de s'y intéresser dr
patrick hannais redick 50 mais le
président du groupe ps au sénat par
exemple d'avoir vu et même à cran cette
semaine y compris s'exprimer devant les
candidats audois seul mitterrand lui ne
se feront sous mitterrand ou françois
hollande par exemple je pourrais dire
que j'en sais quelque chose
ce sont ne se ne se sont jamais
intéressés à ce sujet non s'est il s'y
intéresse tous à présent moi je crois
que c'est la responsabilité principale
des mouvements politiques
c'est à ça qu'il serve c'est leur rôle
dans la constitution ils sont définis
comme ça dans la constitution ils
concourent à l'expression du suffrage
mais je puis aussi assuré que ça n'est
pas parce que
au président de la république s'est
intéressé au sujet que les mouvements
politiques ont
renoncé à cette responsable des
justement vous avez une nouvelle
organisation pour la majorité qui
s'appelle ensemble et qui regroupe donc
votre parti celui d' horizons et celui
d' emmanuel macron comment doit
fonctionner ensemble est-ce qu'il faut
un chef ou est-ce que c'est
naturellement le président de la
république annoncé par le président de
la république le président de la
république a de l'influencé mais c'est
pas un chef de parti le président dary
pic le président de la république il a
naturellement des soutiens ça s'est fait
dans toutes les majorités au travers du
temps mais il est meilleur qu'il ya
dedans tous mais il est avant tout au
dessus des partis
il a avant tout une fonction de défense
des institutions de leur équité il a
avant tout une fonction de garantie aux
yeux des citoyens que tout ça va marcher
de manière juste d'accord qui est le
chef d'ensemble ben c'est richard
ferrand qui pour l'instant qui a été
désigné pour occuper cette
responsabilité avec edouard philippe et
moi comme mon fils mais quasiment
différence un juste qu'est ce qui vous
différencie encore aujourd'hui quelle
est la nécessité de garder trois parties
sous une bannière commune pourquoi ne
pas faire une seule confédération ou un
seul un seul parti est ce que sur le
fond vous proposer des options
différentes non je
nous avons une histoire différente
et nous avons des organisations
différentes
et peut-être
pour le nôtre en tout cas une
philosophie plus caractérisé
la république en marche sous renaissance
patronale s'est pas encore le nom que
qui qu'ils vont adopter l'anglais la
république en marche ça n'est pas une
sensibilité c'est un rassemblement de
sensibilité on va continuer par les
différences toi
les élections législatives sommes
solides pour la suite plus grand jury
constitué
[Musique]
du grand jury rtl le figaro lci invitée
aujourd'hui le haut commissaire au plan
président du mouvement démocrate
françois bayrou le débat est dirigée par
olivier bost françois bayrou avant de
parler des retraites de pouvoir d'achat
d'écologie également une question d'
adria geindre de tf1 lci sur les
élections législatives oui vous
rappeliez il ya quelques instants que ce
sont bien les partis politiques ils se
sont occupés des investitures vous y
avez vous même participé alors peut-être
allez-vous pourra nous éclairer sur un
point on sait que c'est très disputée
les candidatures est compris entre
partis on a observé qu'il n'y avait pas
de candidat de la majorité
présidentielle face à damien abad le
président sortant du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée pourquoi donc
pourquoi ne pas mettre plus imposant la
majorité face à lui parce qu'il est à
quelques personnalités dont nous avons
eu en tant que responsable de ceux de ce
courant de la majorité
l'impression que ils avaient
par leur indépendance d'esprit
par la manière dont ils exercer leur
mandat ou dont ils s'exprimaient en
étant peut-être moins virulent dans les
affrontements systématique on a eu
l'impression que c'était bien de faire
un signe alors même qu'il était le
président du principal groupe
d'opposition à les anglais il vous a
peut-être pas échappé que parmi les élus
qui étaient dans le groupe d'opposition
dans ces groupes d'opposition à la somme
à l'assemblée un certain nombre d'un
bord et de l'autre
se sont désolidarisés des attitudes
agressives ou des accords
désespérant
dans les pyrénées atlantiques
david habib qui était vice-président de
l'assemblée socialiste dans mon propre
département n'aura pas de candidat de la
majorité en face de lui par leur
attitude ils cochent les cas si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi pour rejoindre cette
majoritaire aux yeux c'est à eux de le
dire
peut-être vous aurez observé quelque
chose dans toute ma vie il ya une
attitude que j'ai détesté c'est la
soumission
d'un bout à l'autre alors un
psychanalyste trouverait peut-être des
choses à dire s'il s'y faisait
s'il essayé d'approfondir sa vous êtes
je déteste la soumission je trouve que
l'engagement politique
c'est un engagement où on doit jamais
aliéner sa liberté
et c'est d'ailleurs la constitution et
donc que ces élus là avec des
sensibilités différentes
et puis ces temps peut-être trompé au
fil du temps sur des sujets disent
oui nous regardons ce que le président
et la majorité font au moins avec
considération avec seulement pour sauver
leur poste
en
il peut arriver que ça soit ça j'ai
perdu un jour mon poste de député pour
des raison d'engagements différente de
celle de mes amis bon c'est pas le drame
absolu de perdre un poste de député on
peut se construire et se reconstruire
mais en effet peut-être un certain
nombre d'entre eux ont ils été sensible
à ce à ce risque et ont ils voulu le
conjuré c'est possible aussi noélie avec
une question sur les réseaux sociaux une
question de nos internautes est ce que
maintenant vous vous entendez mieux avec
edouard philippe
e.on s'est jamais mal entendu on avait
des positions différentes il y avait des
tensions il ya eu des tensions entre
nous en raison de ses positions
différentes puis peut-être aussi en
raison notre histoire peut-être aussi en
raison d'une tempérament qui est le nom
du un tempérament un tout petit peu
bouillant je le reconnais je le hais lui
aussi c'est le président de la
république par sa volonté une partie
unique qui vous a rapprochés
non je pense qu'on s'est tous les deux
aperçue que l'espèce de luttes
fratricides
ou en tout cas cousinie side qu'on
essayait de nous imposer que les médias
racontent est à longueur d'articles et
vous même brillamment
c'était 7 est idiot qu'on n'était pas du
tout joué à ces affrontements donc
peut-être un certain nombre de gens
pouvaient profiter et que c'était plus
intéressant dans le moment que nous
vivions et hind essayer de voir ce qui
pouvait nous rapprocher une dernière
question de construire quelque chose
ensemble une dernière question sur ce
sujet dans cinq ans chez ensemble la
désignation du candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ça fonctionne comment qu
à ça c'est une question qui n'a jamais
été traitée vraiment a vraiment ni de
près ni de loin alors peut-être si un
jour ça devient une structure avec des
règles des statuts les sujets tabous plc
être peut être lâchée et puis je vais
vous dire quelque chose
d'élection présidentielle
ça n'est pas une élection qui se décide
par des structures d'appareils
et quand on essaie regarder ce qui vient
de se passer pour les républicains
regardez ce qui vient de se passer pour
le ps quand on essaie on se casse la
figure à tous les coups
l'élection présidentielle elle se
constitue autour
d'itinéraires et de personnalités qui
peu à peu se sédimente dans l'opinion
vous savez comme dans une rivière le il
y à il ya des sédiments de du sable et
puis après ça devient compact qui fait
que
une femme ou un homme a un lien avec les
français et c'est ce lien là qui fait
kiffer le qui fait le choix c'est ce
lien là qui fait l'investiture et tout
le reste en réalité c'est inventer pour
essayer de trouver une solution quand on
n'a pas la personne qui a un lien avec
les français et on vient de le voir si
la surabondamment d'ici là on va évoquer
un gros dossier de ce quinquennat la
réforme des retraites avec game rock r
oui et le report de l'âge de la retraite
on le sait une majorité de français sont
contre alors qu'est ce que doit faire
emmanuel macron est ce qu'il doit
largement organiser la concertation
comme vous le souhaitiez semble-t-il sur
d'autres thèmes en partie de l'émission
ou est-ce qu'il faut qu'il prenne ses
responsabilités en dix ans de toute
façon je considère que c'est
indispensable et donc on y va
parmi les changements de méthode que le
président de la république pendant la
campagne a lui-même abordés même si ça
ne s'est pas vraiment entendu
il ya cette idée que je considère moi je
m'exprime à titre personnel je suis pas
du tout à sa place et il ya cette idée
que le passage en force ne marche jamais
on croit que ça marche on croit que
parce qu'on l'a écrit dans un programme
comme avait essayé de le faire edouard
philippe ouais je n'ai pas en cause
quelques démarches que ce soit mais ça
c'est fait on a vu ça mille fois n'est
ce pas surtout être à 49,3 que nos
institutions et mes jeux à titre
personnel m'exprimant pour moi même et
pas pour d'autres je pense que le
passage en force et une mauvaise
solution
il ya un homme que j'aimais beaucoup
et qui étaient sympathiques avec moi qui
s'appelait vaclav havel qui a été le
très grand président de la
tchécoslovaquie d'abord de la tchéquie
ensuite un philosophe un dramaturge
jeune homme de lettres et vaclav havel
parlant de ceux qui veulent passer en
force
qu'il appelle les impatients politique
ils disaient ils sont comme ces enfants
qui pour faire pousser les arbres plus
vite leurs tirs sur les branches et
c'est exactement ce que je pense je
pense que même sur les problèmes les
plus difficiles
il faut que l'arbre pousse à partir de
son biotope d'autres attirent gens sages
irlandais ne faut pas se précipiter
cette réforme à partir de sa terre à
partir du sol à partir du soleil
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
urgence on peut en six mois faire mûrir
une idée parmi les français si vous avez
la capacité de leur parler avec des
éléments que tous pourront vérifier de
leur parler avec une langue qu'ils
comprennent
de les mettre devant le réel et de leur
proposer les options la solution va
mûrir et vous défendez de sur l'idée
d'un référendum pour à l'heure sur cette
question et jeudi si
cette thèse de la réforme continue que
je défends de la réforme
mûri par les français si cette thèse
échoué si on arrive à un affrontement
alors il y à un moyen d'éviter le
blocage du pays parce que c'est de ça
qu'on a souffert le blocage du pays par
des gens minoritaires ou majoritaires on
n'en sait rien il ya un moyen c'est se
tourner vers le peuple en leur disant
quelque chose de très simple nous avons
construit la réforme la plus juste
possible à nos yeux on la fait pas pour
nous on ne fait pas pour le gouvernement
on la fait pas par idéologie on l'a fait
pour vous et pour que les pensions ne
s'effondre pas vous prenez les
cotisations malgré l'oseraie makonda est
là et là on organise un référendum
vous prenez la constitution le prévoit
sur ce type de sujet prenez le risque de
condamner de réformes si c'est moi ne
pas y avoir doré bien si c'est non il y
aura le gouvernement devra en tirer les
conclusions et puis il y aura un autre
gouvernement michel rocard a dit cent
fois que c'est que c'était une réforme
qu'ils auraient 10 ou 15 gouvernement je
suis persuadé connaît plus près du but
qu'on ne le croit sur le fond vous êtes
à condition qu' il soit ils apparaissent
clairement aux yeux de tout le monde
que la justice dont je parle la justice
c'est quoi les français qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt
les français qui font des métiers
pénibles cela on en tiendra compte dans
la réforme et à condition que on met en
valeur le fait que dans cette réforme en
réalité la retraite choisie ou
la date de la retraite la plus choisie
possible va leur ouvrir des possibilités
nouvelles je connais beaucoup de gens
qui aimeraient bien prolonger mais c'est
possible aujourd'hui de travailler
jusqu'à 60 ans qui a prolongé et
j'ajoute mois avec une incitation on
peut tout à fait imaginer que le
l'organisation de la retraite parce que
si vous décidez de travailler plus
longtemps et puis on vous donne c'est
déjà quelques avantages et c'est déjà le
cas aujourd'hui non mais par exemple si
on à leurs idées personnelles un jeune
je n'engage personne ne veut en temps
des mois bien
on pourrait leur verser une partie de
leur retraite un pourcentage de la
retraite
imaginez qu'on dise vous continuer à
travailler pendant une année ou deux
années de plus on va vous verser 10% de
votre retraite
la prime d'activités pour les retraités
oui d'accord mais vous voyez bien
guillaume roquette sans surprise elle
serait il ya une autre solution ayant
deux pas de pain aller trop vite voyez
bien en quoi cette cette idée que je
défends serait
une idée puissamment incitatrice parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens que ça par
exemple très grand nombre de femmes et
d'hommes qui se retrouvent avec des
enfants pas encore
émancipé
alors qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont l'âge de partir à la re
travaillera en échange d'une sorte d'
avance entre guillemets sur la sur la
retraite et alors qu'est ce que vous que
c'est ce que je sais ce que je défends
donc s'est tu c'est une incitation et si
on construit comme ça un projet dans
lequel les français vont reconnaître
leurs attentes leur diversité et leur
intérêt mais aussi quelque chose qui
ressemble à à l'intérêt général alors je
n'ai pas de doute qu'ils pourront
arriver à le soutenir parce qu'en
travaillant surtout si on laisse pas
bleus quel pays il ya une autre
proposition qui est faite par laurent
berger le patron de la cfdt opposant de
longue date au report de l'âge de la
retraite et lui dit et si on veut
trouver de l'argent pour financer les
retraites il ya qu'à rétablir les sf en
fait rétablir un un impôt sur le capital
sur les sur les 10 % des français qui
ont le plus de patrimoine alors le le
yaka et je le dis avec beaucoup de
respect pour laurent berger mais je ne
crois pas que ce soit adapté parce que
l'idée qu' il suffit de créer de
nouveaux impôts pour financer
le modèle social français est une idée
que je trouve
mal inspiré
j'ai pas de doute qu'il ya des sujets je
pense à la dépendance qui sont des
sujets extrêmement lourd il ya des
sujets qui tiennent aux entreprises ya
des sujets qui tiennent que si chaque
fois on décide que y'a qu'à mettre un
nouvel impôt il entre comme vous savez
je me réjouis des retraites sans lacets
comme vous savez le luron
j'avais proposé une autre démarche pour
l' isf mais aujourd'hui ça prendrait un
sens complètement différent et je crois
que ça ferait apparaître s'adonneraient
à des gens le à des investisseurs le
sentiment que la france en revient à sa
tendance est aujourd'hui un des pays
pour ne pas dire le pays le plus imposé
au monde
et donc je trouve qu'on devrait se
mettre dans ce cadre là qui y est on va
résoudre les questions qui se posent
sans perpétuellement créer de nouveaux
impôts si on peut justement bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie a estimé
que la france se trouvait face à des
difficultés économiques considérables et
que le plus dur était devant nous est ce
que cette situation économique a pas été
si non masqué ou en tout cas oublié dans
la campagne présidentielle il a
complètement raison
les difficultés que nous allons
rencontrer sont à mon sens majeur et
c'est pourquoi je parlais au début d'une
situation préoccupante
spécialement dans l'état social du pays
parce que vous allez avoir à la fois une
france qui est fragilisé par ses
fractures
et des vagues pour ne pas dire des
tsunamis qui arrivent de l'extérieur
j'en cite 2-1 que tout le monde à
l'esprit c'est la guerre en ukraine
si on croit qu'on est au bout des
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine à
mon sens c'est qu'on n'a pas les yeux
ouverts aux séquences économique de
l'inflation conséquences économiques sur
l'énergie conséquences économiques sur
la confiance conséquences économiques
sur la place que l'ukraine occupe dans
le monde agricole et alimentaire
mondiale pas seulement français mais il
ya une deuxième question il ya une
deuxième crise qu'on ne regarde pas
c'est ce qui se passe en chine
[Musique]
le la menace du que vides en chine a
fait que aujourd'hui
dans le port de shanghai
il y a
certains disent plus d'un millier
d'autres disent au moins 500 300 500
gigantesque porte conteneurs qui sont
bloqués qui ne peuvent ni décharger ni
recharger à cause du confinement et les
usines sont bloqués à cause de la
politique qu'on appelle le zéro co vide
ce qui au passage permet de renvoyer les
critiques sur la politique qui a été
celle de la france et de l'europe au
sens large à leur véritable réalité l'a
donc là si nous nous avons la situation
politique est en train de se retourner
noëlie non laissez moi finir leur
démonstration parce que là ce serait pas
juste mais j'en ai pour quelques phrases
sont brièvement vraiment
on va voir ces deux crises la
ce qui se passe en chine c'est
l'interruption des circuits
d'approvisionnement
sur tout les produits et matières
premières je disais il ya certains 10000
d'autres 10500 porte conteneurs en tout
sur la planète il ya 5000
porte-conteneurs qui chacun porte les
plus grands quelque chose comme 23000
cantonales est-ce que vous représentez
ce que c'est pour l'approvisionnement
circuits imprimés
ça va tout changer dans la répartition
des productions je donne un exemple tout
bête un frigo pour être transporté ces
100 dollars ça veut dire que si vous
pouvez économiser presque 100 de l'ars
avait intérêt à le produire chez nous et
donc ces deux crises la vienne et elles
vont se conjuguer avec peut-être ce qui
se prépare du côté du moyen-orient et
donc si vous avez ça en tête alors vous
vous dites que oui la situation que nous
allons affronter est une situation
lourde et alors girard dans ce conte à
gré est ce qu'on peut continuer de
dépenser sans compter est-ce que c'est
l'inflation qui doit guider autrement
dit est-ce qu'il faut tous augmenté à
hauteur de l'inflation temps qu'elle
dure continuer avec l'échec
on retrouve des schémas qu'on a connu
dans notre histoire
alors il ya deux questions est-ce que
l'inflation va durer les économistes
sont très partagés sur ce sujet
certains pensent que
les raisons
profondes de l'inflation sont peut-être
moins présente qu'on ne le croit chez
nous et la france s'en tire mieux du
point de vue de l'inflation que tout
c'est que tous ses voisins vous votre
deuxièmement est-ce qu'on peut dépenser
sakho sans compter et ouvrir les
robinets non non on adule faire pour le
coc vide et c'était juste parce que
c'était une période dans lequel on était
donné mais la loi pouvoir d'achat dans
une examiné à l'assemblée c'est
exactement ça c'est le robinet qui
continuent d'être normes jeune frère je
pense
on a une chose à faire c'est retrouver
les équilibres c'est vrai pour la
retraite
c'est vrai pour la dépense publique et
pour la dette c'est vrai pour la dette
en différenciant la dette qui sert à
l'investissement de la dette qui servent
à mai aux dépenses là quand on va
augmenter et on peut s'en féliciter pour
les gens qui sont concernés mais les
retraites le point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires les minima sociaux il va
bien falloir qu'on creuse encore cette
dette pour financer tout ça bien vous
aurez la réponse
ce que le président de la république
explication de ce que le président de la
république a dit quand il a décrit ce à
quoi son premier ministre devait
s'intéresser doit s'intéresser au social
doit s'intéresser à l'écologie et au
président doit s'intéresser à la brosse
soit productif du pays
j'ai plaidé haut commissariat au plan et
ailleurs en produisant sur la rue des
comtesses de la production parce que un
très grand nombre des réponses aux
questions qui paraissent insolubles se
trouve dans la re création d'un élan
productif mais renie pas du tout parce
que là on a un déficit commercial qui
sur les 12 derniers mois atteint 100
milliards de ruines
vous comprendrez pourquoi je me suis
tellement battu sur ce sujet là
visiblement blick c'est un autre moyen
de rétablir nos comptes pour l'instant
quand je vois les tenants de toutes les
opinions qui se sont exprimées pendant
l'élection présidentielle
je n'ai pas vu souvent de propositions
de baisse de la dépense publique mais je
pense qu'on peut rééquilibrer en faisant
attention c'est pas moi qui vais dire le
contraire sur la tête d'une collectivité
locale dans laquelle on fait et on est
obligé de faire attention
la mairie de pau et l'agglomération dans
laquelle nous vivons on faisait
attention et deux en augmentant
la production du pays les emplois du
pays
exemple la question des retraites elle
est difficile à résoudre mais si on
allait au plein emploi alors vous avez
rééquilibrer la question des retraites
vous voyez que tout se tient le l'idée
qu' on est uniquement à la machette avec
un coupe coupe et que c'est le sait le
seul travail des dirigeants est une idée
fausse on l'a de la marque lada oui vous
avez raison j'ai pas moi qui veux dire
le compère mais le fond de la faire
c'est qu'on se tourne vers les capacités
du pays voir si on peut les mobiliser et
si on les mobilise alors les choses se
rééquilibreront mais c'est un travail de
longue haleine raison de plus pour
insister sur la très grande
responsabilité du gouvernement qui vient
et cette responsabilité pour moi c'est
de transformer en politique un programme
la volonté qui s'est exprimé dans un
power play clic c'est-à-dire actions de
tous les jours et vision de l'avenir du
pays et parmi ses missions et à la
transition écologique larchitecture d'un
premier ministre chargé de cette
question là avec deux super ministre est
ce que pour vous c'est assez clair c'est
fonctionnel donc on verra ça dépend des
personnalités mais ce que j'ai
ce que j'ai en tête depuis longtemps ces
cônes à trois grandes questions
écologiques devant
la première de ces grandes questions
c'est l'énergie
le nous avons avec le commissariat au
plan produit un rapport qui je crois a
changé l'état d'esprit autour du
nucléaire et toute proposition c'est
pourquoi il faut faire attention à la
politique vos propositions politiques
quand mélenchon essaie et s'est investi
ces candidats proposent de sortir du
nucléaire
vous voyez bien que vous déséquilibre
est complètement et la démarche
écologique et la démarche économique du
pays c'est une décision si elle était
appliquée qui serait complètement
irresponsable
songez qu'il ya de telles demandes en
électricité qu'on va voir exploser le
prix de l'électricité sur le marché
libre et cette électricité convainc
qu'on achète aurait elle est produite de
en envoyant des millions de tonnes de
co2 dans l'atmosphère souhaitait rester
car du charbon pour piloter tout ça
c'est pardon mais les défis que vous
vous dit stella c'est des défis qui vont
prendre des années vous souhaitez rester
à votre poste de commissaire au plan
c'est une responsabilité à laquelle je
suis attaché que j'ai voulu voir
renaître et qui peut être équilibré
développer mais c'est des sujets dont je
parlerai acquis avec qui de droit
gdj qui fait aussi des études en terme
de prospective propose lui un
secrétariat général aux soutenabilité ça
sera une question de soutenabilité
l'écologie vous êtes d'accord avec ça
excusez moi moi je suis en pyrénées donc
secrétariat général de soutenabilité du
jargon chez nous on a beaucoup de mal à
comprendre ce que c'est donc le vous
voyez bien c'est toute la question au
fond de la stratégie pour que l'on
trouve
un équilibre à long terme donc je suis
pas pour des riens machin techno
supplémentaires je suis pour qu'on
prenne nos responsabilités
je disais énergie c'est la première
grande question il ya une deuxième
grande question c'est la biodiversité la
question elle est essentiellement
agronomique loup d'abord agronomique
c'est la question du sol comment on rend
le solde à troyes le vivent 4 à une
question dès la troisième question c'est
changer nos modes de vie pour devenir
frugaux raisonnable pour réparer plus
souvent qu on achète
on va passer quand ces derniers leur
croissance par par françois bayrou nord
mais moi je suis au contraire de cuisson
abord une question très rapide comme sur
l'ukraine de son enseigne la commission
le président ukrainien s'est exprimée
négativement ces derniers jours sur le
président français il estime que mel
macron essayé en vain de dialoguer avec
vladimir poutine et il ne juge pas
correct que le président français soit
prêt selon lui à faire des concessions
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire il ya de
la gratitude de la part de volodymyr
zemsky
non c'est quelqu'un que je respecte mais
il est à la tête d'un pays en guerre
attaqué par son voisin
avec des changements stratégiques très
important
dans l'art de faire la guerre au moment
où on se souviendra très longtemps ce
qui est en train de se passer une armée
surpuissante qui est arrêté par des
moyens modernes et la volonté d'un
peuple
donc je comprends très bien sa position
mais je dis que le devoir du président
de la république française pas seulement
sa préférence et son devoir c'est
d'essayer d'éviter l'embrasement général
moi je pense à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent et à leurs enfants il ya des
risques d'embrasement génère
l'embrasement général de troisième
guerre mondiale ya des risques de
contagion terrifiante et donc celui qui
à la tête de la france à la tête de
l'europe essaie de maintenir malgré tout
le lien en dépit 2 des choix qui sont
fous qui soient insupportables
celui-là rempli son devoir et fait son
travail merci beaucoup françois bayrou
s'était ce grand jury que vous pouvez
retrouvez sur rtl.fr et sur nos
applications